denis laprise roule en tesla
ça peut nous paraître extravagant de
posséder une voiture électrique de 90
mille dollars
on décolle mais ici c'est plutôt banal
la baisse là on l'appelle la camry de la
silicon valley là où se trouvent les
bureaux et les usines de montage
tesla c'est une pme à côté de facebook
dont le siège social se trouve non loin
de là on pourrait tout les nommer il ya
un tel foisonnement d'entreprises de
haute technologie qui ont leur siège ici
les plus grosses comme gougaud et la
reine de la silicon valley y ait du
monde entier à pau denis laprise lui il
est le roi de sa roulotte en bordure de
magasins target et il rêve de devenir le
roi du commerce en ligne
parce qu'il est aussi le concepteur
d'une application qui pourrait le rendre
riche puisque en fait c'est qu'on
peaufine un produit on se sent vraiment
la technologie bonne croissance
son produit s'appelle club ça aide c'est
un service à l'auto nouvelles manières
ça fonctionne comme ceux ci le client
fait des achats par internet chez un
détaillant participants dans ce cas-ci
targus
une heure plus tard il reçoit un
courriel qui confirme que sa commande
est prête il se présente ensuite en
voiture prendre possession de sa
marchandise près du magasin aussi de
clubs sign 60 voix seront convoyés 500
lits
grâce à la géolocalisation les employés
cup side savent que le client approche
du magasin cette femme avec trois
enfants dit adorer qui obsède un service
gratuit qui obsède est en rodage dans
onze magasins target de la baie de san
francisco
l'an prochain on veulent implanter dans
15 villes américaines sont réussis 15 et
la pression en gros on va faire 50 ans
on va faire simple parce qu'on grossier
s'est graduellement pour occire il faut
trouver de l'argent
si c'est le premier bureau de google 7,6
au mieux après avoir quitté la gare à la
montagne et premier buzz en paye le prix
vous êtes en prix qu'en sont des ménages
us c'est vraiment là les premiers
bureaux de burgos et sol
les jeunes créateurs de google
fréquentait certainement les cafés de
university avenue à palo alto
c'est souvent dans ces cas fait que les
inventeurs et les investisseurs font des
rencontres express
ils ont quelques minutes pour avoir un
coup de foudre et conclure un marché
c'est grâce à cet homme
j'ai ouï jahnke club saad a pu obtenir
un premier financement
un million et demi jerry yang c'est le
cofondateur de yahoo qui se spécialise
maintenant dans l'investissement dans
des entreprises en démarrage qui est
intéressant avec avec sa ferme sexuelle
seul le seul de ce partenaire donc ils
bougent extrêmement avec actionnaire
unique quelque chose et jerry yang à
bouger vite pour cup side on est chaud
comme ça mais c'est comme ça
ça fait de me connaître
les nouveaux locaux c'est plus qu'une
roulotte c'est une véritable entreprise
de nouveaux investisseurs ont cru au
projet est injecté 8 millions au total
une levée de fonds de près de 10
millions en neuf mois seulement
ingénieurs techniciens ont été recrutés
pour faire fonctionner et améliorer
l'application club side
vous avez combien d'employés 35 ans
premier temple alors que les honneurs
vous aviez on était trop tout un
parcours pour ce petit gars de
saint-félicien au lac-saint-jean denis
laprise a fait un bac en informatique à
l'université laval et avec des amis a
lancé en 2005
à québec une compagnie spécialisée dans
la cartographie web qu'on voulait pas
travailler pour des banques comme ceux
ci ont notamment porté sur des projets
qu en 2010 la compagnie de québec est
acheté par à pau et denis laprise des
ménages en californie il y travaillera
trois ans en cartographie web et
quittera appose en 2013
oger j'aime construire j'aime créer
partout et le voici maintenant avec sa
conjointe
orphée martin originaire de saint tubal
de portneuf et leurs deux jeunes enfants
installés dans cette silicon valley
obsédé par la réussite c'est très
compétitif même les maires au parc c'est
toujours une image un blog les marins
des compagnies ton mari qu'est-ce qui
fait ou est ce qu'ils travaillent yacht
aux jo en background les compagnies la
technologie la performance
performance et compétition les livres
que l'on voit ici juste à côté de kurdes
cèdent sont engagés par le géant google
en californie notamment google s'est
lancé dans les commandes en ligne et
livraison à domicile pour comme ça donc
c'est pas gagné il faudra prouver la
pertinence de leurs applications
mais le travail acharné donne le droit
de rêver comme l'ont fait les créateurs
d'apo dans la silicon valley il ya 40
ans un jour ça sera vous autres
c'est impossible avoue que vous tentez
de mégots dans ma peau c'est pas
impossible